يروي مسلسل Smash Hit That الحالي الذي تعرضه قناة HBO نهاية العالم التي
تشهدها الزومبي على مستوى العالم والتي تغذيها
الفطريات، ويتساءل الكثير منا عما إذا كان يمكن أن يحدث ذلك في الحياة الواقعية، هل يمكن أن يساعدنا هو أو كبير المراسلين الطبيين لدينا هو الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا في صباح الخير،
لذا
فإن هذا النوع من الفطريات  الفطريات تمثل في
الواقع تهديدًا،
يجب أن أقول أولاً إنني
شاهدت جزءًا من هذا العرض الآن
كواجب منزلي لهذه المهمة وهو
عرض مثير للاهتمام حقًا،
ويجب أن أقول ما يدور حوله العرض
هو الفطريات التي تحفز هذا بالفعل  هذا
السلوك الذي يغير العقل لدى البشر
لا يمثل تهديدًا حقيقيًا ولكن من أين
حصلوا على الفكرة كانت فكرة
هذا الفطر المعروف باسم أوركيد كورديسيبس
أم في الواقع يحدث نوعًا من التغيير
في النمل ولا أعرف أنني لا أعرف  تعرف
مدى قدرتك على رؤية هذا ولكن هذه
نملة أصيبت بالعدوى وهي
تحتضر وتتسلق شجرة وتتسلق
نباتًا فقط تقفل هناك
ويمكنك أن ترى في الجزء العلوي من الشاشة
هناك في المنتصف  الشاشة
تنمو هذه الفطريات فعليًا من
رأسها الآن والسبب وراء قيامها بذلك
هو أنها جردت النملة
من جميع عناصرها الغذائية، لقد كانت الفطريات
طفيلية تمامًا وهي الآن
تخلق البوغ، يا إلهي، سوف
تنتشر  بذوره وتصيب
النمل الآخر، إنها برية، هذا هو حقًا ما
يتعلق بـ opiocordyceps مرة أخرى هو
اسم تلك الفطريات الآن ولحسن الحظ
ليس شيئًا يحدث عند البشر
ولكن هذا هو المكان الذي حصل فيه مبدعو العرض على
فكرة مشاهدة هذا المسلسل التلفزيوني
ما يفعله بالنمل بشكل عام
هناك أنواع مختلفة من
العلاقات بين مسببات الأمراض
والبشر، هذه العلاقات التكافلية
ويمكننا تفكيكها نوعًا ما ولكن
التبادلية هي واحدة منها حيث
قد تستفيد أنواع القوارب من التفكير في أشياء
مثل المرجان والطحالب على سبيل المثال
التعايش  هو حيث يستفيد أحدهما
والآخر ليس له أي تأثير، مثل قيام
طائر ببناء عش في شجرة ولكن
ما رأيته للتو كان تطفلًا حيث
يستخدم أحد مسببات الأمراض
الكائن الحي الآخر لمصلحته الخاصة في
هذه الحالة يستخدم الفطر النملة ل
ينتشر بشكل أكبر في
الغابة، إنها برية وهذا ما
يحاولون البناء عليه في هذا العرض